[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
much greater than what divides us this
morning how a pair of
tech savvy tech savvy brothers in
california
are working to make election day safe so
you've got ten zing and zubin carvalho
they started making face shields for
family members in front line health care
jobs
now as our dr tara narula shows us
they're also working to protect poll
workers
[Applause]
[Music]
when the pandemic hit twelve-year-old
tenzing and fourteen-year-old zubin took
their robotics team skills
and transformed their 3d printer into
a lifesaver our grandparents are in the
70s
they're still seeing patients in their
nursing homes hospitals and offices
so we wanted to find a way to keep them
safe what started with helping their own
family this is 3d printed his is
injected molded
became a push community-wide where the
mouse spread of us
and we started getting requests for
hundreds of shields and we're now made
up of eight high schools eight
elementary schools
nine robotics teams from five different
school districts
face shields can take up to four hours
to print then they are sanitized
and sent out we want people realize also
there's more staff to nursing homes we
donated to custodial and cafeteria staff
because
also they play a key role in those
ecosystems as well the brothers
non-profit
socal face shields for frontline workers
was created to make sure
everyone who needed a shield received
one my mom
is actually a frontline worker she works
in a grocery store and she interacts
with people
thousands of people every day fellow
robotics teammate maya
keys joined as well seeing how this
impacts her
this project gave me an opportunity to
give back and to help even if it was
minor at first it was but now it's huge
huge
as in the group has printed and donated
over fifteen thousand
shields to frontline workers who may not
have been
first in line my name is christopher i'm
a healthcare worker from new jersey my
name is marlene coming from the nepal
reservation
i am very thankful for these facials
that were donated to us
it's kept me coronavirus free for six
months
thank you thank you thank you after
sending donations
across the country the boys are now
looking at a different front line
yeah these are 1 600 they're reusable
our main focus right now are election
workers since there's an important
upcoming election
that's going to happen this year and we
want to make sure
that they would stay safe since they
helped keep
the process of our democracy going this
was the first i've heard of
students i've heard of some maybe some
non-profits donating
to hospitals but i had not heard of any
donating to the elections office
riverside county registrar voters
rebecca spencer
can now distribute over 1600 donated
shields
how important is it that this group has
donated face shields to your poll
workers
it's great that way we don't have to use
taxpayer funds to go out and purchase
ppe
the two of you can't vote yet but you're
donating
to poll workers and supporting the
election process how does that make you
feel makes us feel proud of ourselves
as just a kid we're actually
contributing to this election system so
it makes us very happy
oh boy thank you tara no ruler we need
more kids like that
it's funny tony during the piece i was
thinking the same thing you asked how
old are they again 12 and 14. wow
because i was following what they were
doing and i thought i guess they're in
college somewhere
right they sound like they're in college
somewhere and just the way they said
took their 3d tech skills because they
play a role in the ecosystems as well
yes when they were helping other people
bravo follow brothers
and one good thing they didn't stop
there and they thought okay what else
can we do with this now the poll workers
because
they're front lines of democracy yeah
very good point what they do is very
important